wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and get some amazing
motivation from the one and only marissa
pierre
enjoy
[Music]
your mind responds to the pictures and
words the fastest way to change anything
is to change the pictures and words
and it's such an easy thing to do
i'm terrified i'm elated i'm useless i'm
amazing i have no memory my memory is
compelling i can't speak to people what
i have to say
is easy i find it easy to speak to
anyone
this is the most vexing rule of the mind
for every therapist and coach in the
room it's the one my clients have the
hardest time with
your mind loves what is familiar if your
mind could choose it would stay with
what's familiar and never go to what's
unfamiliar we're in a ward city
and that's interesting because years ago
at night they shut the door and we
stayed in the wall we didn't think do
you know i feel like going for a
midnight stroll i think i wonder i'm a
bit bored of being in this same old same
old i want some variety i think i'll
open the gate wander off and find
another tribe they might have killed you
or eaten you
we learnt familiar made us safe who here
notices with their kids and they
literally want the same cup
the same bowl the same cereal i took my
daughter to finland to see santa claus
she watched a little mermaid in finnish
the whole time and she didn't that was
okay and finished because she knew she'd
watched it 110 times where i'm like babe
his father christmas is only mummy i
want to watch the little mermaid it's
like well next time we'll just stay home
and watch a movie then she did actually
get into it but it made her feel good
she used to play this game she had so
many barbies and ken would come up in
his car and he was picked the same one
he never picked another one to go to the
ball because they like familiar
it makes them safe you know how many
kids yeah they want the same story every
night
but familiar also makes us safe so
here's a rule of the mind and it's a
very important rule to put into practice
my mind likes what is familiar and it
doesn't like what's unfamiliar okay
but i can make anything negative
unfamiliar and anything positive
familiar let's start with praise it's
the most simple but the most powerful
i meet clients who are never praised i
met one girl whose dad said you're so
rubbish just like your mother
god knows what you've got going if any
man asks you out snap them up because
you are nothing you're not interesting
you're not attractive when you get
pregnant you'll blow up just like her
and be a big fat mess so if anyone wants
to be with you i can't imagine why take
them
and she heard that a lot so she had this
interestingly if i've got nothing to
offer the world and i did a lot of work
with her and she went out she went was
just amazing it was like magic this guy
came up and he asked me out and he was
so nice i mean actually made another
date and he picked me up in his car and
took me out for dinner told me i was
amazing i'm never seeing him again
i'm not really sure no no he was too
good for me i'm like oh
let's change that wording to his
behavior was so unfamiliar
i don't recognize praise or nicest of
somebody believing i'm worth something
and i want to run back to the familiar
guys i have to beg to take me out or
seeing my friends i pay the bill and
they remind me of my dad and i'm like
well guess what you're not supposed to
have sex with your dad so there's a clue
if someone is like your dad i don't
think you should be getting into bed
with them and i think you need to make
that unfortunate people like it when you
make them laugh so she went right so i
said you need to go out with this guy
and this is what you do you keep saying
i will make this familiar
he rings me when he says he will i make
it familiar he texts me i'll make it
familiar i will make it familiar and she
ended up marrying him she's very happy
how weird the other guy called me and
said what happened to me she went what
the guy who never called me you never
called me so i just let you go
so you have to say
let's do it with all of you how many of
you find praise a little unfamiliar
how many of you find praising yourself
even more unfamiliar
okay so if you're never praised and
you're criticized a lot and christmas is
familiar when someone goes wow i love
that teacher oh i got it free it's got a
hole in it i've had it eight years i
loved your speech didn't you notice i
missed out the best bit no i thought it
was amazing i hear you're the best
salesperson in your team
yeah but not in my county there's
another guy way better than me so if
praise isn't familiar you will reject
praise but
you'll add in what's really a criticism
so the one of the best things you can do
that will change your life
is to make praising yourself familiar
and to make criticism unfamiliar the
body holds on to pain and stress and
tension and grief
and we carry around all this stuff and
yet we really don't have to if just more
people knew
even to say i'm enough every day
and to say another of my favorite things
to go is i'm choosing this and i'm
choosing to feel great i'm choosing to
work on my website or weekend i'm
choosing to go to the gym i don't love
it but i love having a six-pack i'm
choosing to say no to krispy kreme
donuts and yes to apples love krispy
kremes do you i could eat 12 of them
right now oh they're so good
but i choose these
yeah and if you say i'm choosing to do
this and choosing to feel great about it
your mind has a very clear image the way
you feel about everything is down to two
things the pictures you make in your
head
and the words you say to yourself
there's nothing else so if you choose to
run going i'm running so i'm raising
money for charity so i'm gonna complete
this run
even though my feet hurt my knee hurts
because i'm going to raise money but you
could run going oh i hate this it's so i
could be at home watching netflix i
haven't eaten and now my knee hurts and
then you'll have to stop
so when you keep saying i'm choosing
because yeah so if you're an olympic
athlete you would choose to get up at
4am and train if you are a diabetic you
choose to put a needle in your arm if
you wear lenses you choose to jab your
finger in your eye but you don't go i
hate it i don't i can't accept it and i
can't change it imagination is more
powerful than knowledge when dealing
with your own mind and the mind of
others if i said to any of you come and
stand on this chair who would come and
stand on this chair
i'll give you a hundred dollars to stand
on this chair sure if i said well now
the chair
is that's is on top of that spire on the
highest building in thailand who's going
to climb up and stand in it for a
hundred dollars who would do that
some people would because they've got a
good imagination if i can stand on it
there i can send most people go no i
could fall you've got a little tiny
plank up here you can walk the plank
when it's on the floor
put the plank between two high-rise
buildings who's going to walk it
not many people because the
imagination that you could fall and kill
yourself is way more powerful than the
knowledge that i did this on the ground
it's wide enough
fear of flying
knowledge says it's actually the safest
place in the world the most dangerous
part of a flight is actually the drive
to the airport that's way more dangerous
than being in the plane do you think the
imagination cares we're going in a
flying coffin i'm hurtling through the
air and that guy looks like he's come
straight out of isis
and he's in the bar i think he's going
to blow up the plane
and then you feel terrible the other
person's going i'm watching a movie i've
always wanted to watch the shape of
water this is so great
here's my time again to do nothing
so whatever you imagine will defeat
logic or defeat knowledge and when
dealing with children
people do logical why are you so bad why
can't you get it what's going on why are
you so naughty
and that doesn't work i never say to
kids why are you bad again what happened
to you you can only love another person
to the degree that you love yourself and
another person can only love you to the
degree that they
love themselves and so if you go through
life feeling you're unlovable
that will always affect the quality of
the relationships you have
and if you date or marry or live with
someone who thinks they are unlovable
it's very hard to have a really healthy
great relationship if the person you are
with feels unlovable of you
at some deep level think that you are
unlovable and more
problems occur from people attracting
the wrong relationship staying in the
wrong relationship
because they feel unlovable i see people
in our office time and time and time
again who were the wrong person
and they're too scared to leave in case
they won't find someone else they say
well we've been together for so long
what's the point
but everything changes when you know
that you are lovable and you see
lovability is essential to being happy
and i have many people who go well you
know i've never felt love being loved is
just a foreign country to me
i don't know what love is i've gone
through my whole life
never having had love and marilyn monroe
bless her heart somebody said to once
marilyn
what is this thing about you wearing
those really tight dresses and dancing
in front of all of those soldiers with
everything hanging out she said i'm
going to quote her word for word
i need the whole world to love me
i must belong to everyone because i've
never belonged to anyone or anything in
my entire life
and i probably never will and there was
a girl who was beautiful
stunning
engaging everybody loved marilyn except
marilyn but you see
if you can't love yourself
nothing really matters you do know don't
you that people who are critical
have so much criticism reserved for
themselves they actively dislike
themselves and you're actually showing
me
and the entire office that you really
don't like yourself by critiquing me
yeah by critic you're just showing me
yeah critical people always have
criticism reserved for themselves they
are full of self-criticism but they
reflect it out and superior people and
happy people always praise and people
who feel inadequate always criticize
because criticize withers you
and praise builds you up
and if you can use those five clinics
thanks for sharing could you repeat that
are you trying to hurt my feelings won't
work i'm not letting it in
since we're sharing did you know what is
running your critical behavior
you don't let it in and being able to
not let in criticism that too will
change your life it it makes you
bulletproof you can't stop people being
mean and having a horrible day and we
now have trolling which is becoming an
epidemic so it's actually worse our kids
used to get bullied at school and go
home to a sanctuary another bullied
online now they're bullied online on the
phone
and it's it never ends and they feel
really attacked and see when you find
trolls they're usually really miserable
and unhappy but they love the power
because they have no power they live on
their own or with their mum they have no
life
i mean we had a terrible situation in
england where somebody was trolling this
person whose child had been kidnapped
and when they exposed her she killed
herself
which was a terrible thing for her but
obviously her sense of shame that she
was outed
and to kill herself but she must have
felt terrible i felt so sorry for her
but she was very vicious in her trolling
but that's a really unhappy person she
needed a lot of help
but when you can teach people to come
back from criticism without fighting or
going well i hate you too or you're all
shut up or crying when you can just
teach them look
i'm not letting it it's like if i try to
give you a gift you go and i don't need
that gift i'm holding the gift i can't
give you something if you don't take it
i can't serve papers on you unless you
accept them i can't serve a volley to
you unless you volley it back
so when you learn that people can try
and give you anything but if you don't
accept it
you haven't let it in
and if you don't let it in it can't hurt
you it just hurts the person who's left
holding it but i find that even with
cancer if you have that belief i'm going
to trial this stuff but it won't work
and you know it's i'm riddled with it
and there's no hope and they start to
read all these terrible diagnosis i mean
in england you are not allowed to say to
them you've got 10 months to live
because that's what happens they turn
into the 10 months
you cannot diagnose what do they tell
them they just say you know we're going
to do this and this and
you may not survive this but you could
and and in the same way that if you're
having surgery and they go look this is
a complete mess in here there's just no
way
even in surgery your subconscious is
hearing
what's going on around you and
there are many people who come out of a
coma who said you know i heard
everything the hearing is the last thing
to go
and so
if you make a choice to talk to yourself
better
you can bounce back you might as well
use your mind as much as you possibly
can
to be well and like all computers think
with your brain is it's always switched
on
and it records everything the way you
feel about everything is down to two
things the pictures you make in your
head
and the words you say to yourself so if
you watch people on a roller coaster are
they screaming because they're happy or
terrified who knows
the mind doesn't even know actually
but if you say i'm excited
and this is thrilling
or i'm terrified and i hate it you
actually will get the same response you
can even just change the words and not
the pictures because the words create
the picture so imagine you had to
go on stage or go for an audition or go
for an assessment with your body oh my
god i'm so scared and it's going to be
terrible i know i'm going to break out
in a sweat and i know when he asks me a
question i'm going to open my mouth and
go
or you can go i'm excited this is my
opportunity to show him who i am and
what i can do for this company i've got
20 minutes on my own with a boss to
present him some ideas i have i'm
excited your mind doesn't question that
so you can be excited or nervous you can
be terrified or ecstatic they kind of
feel the same why do we get addicted to
the workaholic culture to being busy
people are so busy being busy because it
makes them feel validated make something
i've got so much to do i've got so much
on i'm so busy
i must be enough here's the truth you
are already enough
so i see in our culture people working
all the time taking work home we now
have phones and laptops we work in a
restaurant on the commute we're sending
emails answering emails we've got caught
up in a big lie
if i'm busy i'm important if i'm busy
i'm valid i'm always doing something
working working working being busy busy
busy
i feel i must matter i must be
significant i must be enough
but actually that's not true
when you're working all the time your
mind gets overheated it's rather like
your computer or your phone you use your
phone
runs out of power and you recharge it if
you keep taking it back every minute
it never gets to recharge and you are
rather like a computer or a phone you
need to recharge we're doing nothing at
all
switch on and work for eight hours with
lots of breaks and then switch off do
nothing
you see you're called a human being
not a human doing
and if you're a human being it means you
can be
not do
and this belief that when you're busy
you'll achieve more is untrue all
schools know that you teach for maybe an
hour and then have recess or a break
people work better when they stop you
know many years ago i had an idea for a
book
and i took the idea to a publisher and
then hey we love this but but
we want more can you do another eight
chapters i'm like i don't know but i've
got a great belief say yes to every i
said yes of course of course i can do
those eight chapters
and i really had no idea because i'd
written the book i'd given it all i had
didn't think there was anything left and
i could have gone home i thought right
got to sit at my desk and find the
chapters but i knew
that in not working it would come to me
i was driving along one day and all of a
sudden
two chapters filled my head i stopped
the car pulled out a check book wrote it
all down
carried on driving as i wrote out those
two chapters three more came and two
more came
in being not busy
driving chilling relaxing listening in
my mind came up with the answers
and geniuses do not work a genius or
often lie under a tree in nature and go
that's when i get my best ideas einstein
used to sit in a chair with a huge ball
bearing like a shot put in his hand and
the chair would rock and he'd go to
sleep and he would drop it and he would
wake him up and he'd wake up full of
ideas full of inventions
and you can do that too please don't
believe he must be at your desk working
so hard
because creative people get their best
ideas when they are not working
i worked with a very successful person
who worked for television and she said
you know my boss keeps saying you need
to be at your desk at nine you need to
be here until six i said tell him the
truth is okay
listen i'm a creative
my mind comes up with ideas in the
shower when i'm making dinner when i'm
sitting in the garden if i'm at my desk
from nine to six i am less creative than
when i'm doing something else oh okay
as long as you produce the material i
require i don't really care where you
are so she stopped having to believe
i've got to be on i got to be seen to be
at work busy busy busy
i gotta multitask make dinner shop
create ideas stop
just be
don't do
your best ideas will come when you're
not working
sometimes it's when you're doing nothing
that your mind gets creative remember
something else your mind is set up
to answer your question so when you say
how can i come with a great idea how
could i find a great idea for a book or
a pilot or a business and just leave it
your mind will go ahead and find the
answer
but the conscious and subconscious are
very different and the subconscious
works best
when the conscious is not working let's
give you a great example you want to
remember something ah you should
remember the name of that book that
rhetoric what is it
don't know then you're going to think oh
it just popped into my head when you're
dealing with the subconscious mind the
creative mind
the less the conscious is there the
better it responds where did i put my
keys i don't know
but i went to do something else and
suddenly up popped an image my keys are
in the fruit bowl i remember now
but when you're consciously trying
trying trying trying
is very trying trying is lying so forget
about the conscious give it to your
subconscious hey subconscious show me
an idea give me an idea show me
what i should be doing and i trust that
you'll do that and i'm not going to be
looking with you
and i can't find someone saying to my
mind hey mine tell me where i put it hey
mind
give me an idea for this next talk for
this next youtube video
and my subconscious is designed to
answer any question i give it
well i start with how how can i do this
but when i say i don't know
let me try and try and try
don't try it will all work out please
stop being busy
smart people work less you don't need to
work harder
you need to work smarter you can do
three times as much in less time if you
open your mind to your possibilities and
stop trying
don't be busy you'll like a phone
recharge take then when you take time
off don't think oh well i'm i'm just
reading a magazine should be reading a
book i'm just watching trash i should
watch something educational no
take the time to do nothing
i spent a lot of time with tribes and
they do spend a lot of time doing
nothing
because you're recharging like a battery
when you recharge you work better you
have better ideas you're more productive
when you do less
and recharging when you do more
take some time out
think of yourself like a battery stop
being busy and instead be productive
work smarter not harder i have a lot of
friends and i've
i've seen it throughout my life
sometimes sometimes it's like okay i
keep i leave one bad relationship and i
go to the next bad relationship i had a
little theory on this i want to test it
out on you i think it's a reflection of
you
well the person that you end up with
there's people like okay i keep finding
the same person i'm like well maybe you
have to change yourself because you're
going to keep attracting yourself
completely correct if you think you're
not lovable
your belief is i'm going to get dumped
well nobody says i'm not loving no but
they feel it they believe it they am i
okay
do i look are you sure
could you come into my life and make me
feel better and you see these people who
don't really believe they love when they
say the other person please love me
could you love me someone's like sure
yeah
and then they go i don't want to love
you i'm bored now or they might go no
not at all so if you give someone the
permission
to make you feel good they can make you
feel bad of course somebody can enhance
it
so if you feel unlovable if you feel not
enough the scourge of the modern world
because we're told
you're enough if you're tall if your
breasts are up here if you've got a
six-pack if you wear designer labels if
you've if you've got a nice house you've
got a nice car if you haven't got that
you're not enough so
we buy into it
and then we try to find someone to make
us feel enough knowing that we're not
enough if you think you're not enough
your belief is i'm going to get dumped
so if i pick a loser will they just dump
me early
i can i don't have to prolong the pain
so imagine i don't think i'm good enough
i've got to find a guy who also thinks
i'm not good enough and he's also not
good enough and then that's going to end
early but i found someone amazing
and they let me go now no i'm not good
enough because that great guy left me
but that idiot alcoholic well he wasn't
good enough for anybody anyway
so attracting toxic people is less
painful because they weren't it's never
going to work out
so i mean simply i only like married
people it's like yeah because they're
not available to you
you have a belief that love isn't
available so you have a wild affair with
someone who's married and it all goes
wrong
because that's what you expected
if you think love isn't available you're
not going to put yourself in front of
some amazing
quality person who could love you
because if they left you that would hurt
so much more
than some loser in a bar who prefers
drink to you children can only
work in the present tense they don't
understand tomorrow my little girl said
mommy is it tomorrow today
she didn't know what yesterday today and
tomorrow is it tomorrow now is it
tonight today because they don't
understand they only understand now
that's why with a baby when you leave
the room they think you're never coming
back and so children aren't really great
at future pacing
children can only respond to words that
make pictures the more vivid the picture
the more powerful they respond so don't
say you're a good kid
say you are an amazing kid what i love
about you is you've got a natural gift
for science or what i love about you is
you're so good at cooking what i love
about you is how much you love learning
it doesn't matter if you don't get great
grades you love learning the more you
can make the picture good see i have so
many kids who are twins ago i was called
twins twins lunches ready twins get in
the car and they had no identity don't
do that don't dress your kids the same
don't say i love you because you're
smart because when you label a child you
limit them even a good label i love you
because you're beautiful kids here and
if i wasn't
you wouldn't don't do that i love you
because you're lovable and when you grow
up people are going to love you one of
my clients that i can't find love my dad
just said to me every day no one's ever
going to love you like i do well there's
a program
you say to your kid you're so lovable
you're going to find so many people who
love you like i love you
so a child's mind doesn't recognize
neutral words how people say to a baby
don't touch
and then they touch
because don't is a new touch they know
what touches don't touch don't keep
touching it stop touching it they can
only hear the words touching it
you can say that's very fragile and it's
very important to mommy as i say to my
little girl when you're walking across
the house with a drink don't spill it
don't look you've spilt it now i knew it
you always spill it i go darling when
you look at when you you got to look at
the cup and not the television and if
you look at the cup while you walk
you'll keep it up right and then
everything will stay in the cup they
understand stuff that makes a picture
don't spill your juice i guarantee
they're going to spill it every day you
go you just you just can't stop spilling
you're just a messy kid and four days
ago i'm so messy i'm always spilling
stuff what's wrong with me you are
conditioned that's what's wrong with you
but you can be unconditioned like that
so a child mind responds better to
specific words and instruction so they
don't understand later they do respond
to positive words you must with children
eliminate every negative word you're bad
you're naughty
good kids do bad things smart people do
silly things say to a child you're a
great kid
why did you do that that's not you
you're a good kid and they go well you
said you liked her more than me no i
didn't well i heard that and so if you
start with you can't do it all the time
our kids push our buttons as i said they
know you're my teacher darling you're
teaching me how to cope with someone who
gets pain all over the carpet my
daughter's an artist i'm tidy she's
messy i wasn't designed to give birth to
myself how boring would that have been
she's nothing like me i'm nothing like
her we learn from each other
it didn't make our life perfect but it
made it easier
so children also respond to you are you
can you always you do you all know the
story about the class that were given to
a teacher and the teachers of these kids
the geniuses we predicted the best and
you are the genius teacher we've done
these secret tests genius kids genius
teacher we know you'll get genius
results which of course they did then
they went well we picked you at random
and we pick the kids at random but if
you believe something
it becomes true i was teaching
my course and and i heard this story i
just trained a graduate and i was so
proud of it because she said you know my
first client was an anorexic girl and
when i talked to her
using rtt i said what
because we always say the same thing
what was going on when you first began
to have this it's called what i call
what lies beneath and she said um
well i was 11 years old and opened my
dad studying he was looking at porn and
he was panting you know like a dog and i
remember standing at the door thinking
oh
i never want anyone to look at me the
way he's looking at that girl i would
die
if
a man looked at me the way my dad is
looking at that girl now that's actually
a command to the mind do anything and
everything to make sure no man ever
looks at me
the way he's looking at her
and that's when she became anorexic when
you're anorexic the ovaries don't
develop you don't you don't get breasts
you lose your hair
but what was even more interesting is a
girl in the audience said that's so
bizarre because i'm bulimic
and my dad used to
i used to drop me off from the divorce
and go look at your mom look at her in
those tigers who does she think she is
she just looks like a [ __ ] and i
thought i
never want my husband to ever
talk about me like that and i'm so fat
oh my gosh he would never talk or
anything like that so
same almost the same scenario the same
request of the mind i couldn't cope if
anyone spoke about me like that
and one became anorexic and one became
obese
because the mind took the command do
anything and everything to make sure no
one ever
looks at me like that you have exactly
the same situation you ever had if you
change how you talk about it even to
yourself
the situation would change if you go my
kid is a nightmare yeah they drive me
insane i use that all the time and you
start to say my kids are a challenge
yeah that's what they do
you got the same kid the same situation
but you feel better because you start to
say yeah they're a challenge but you
know that comes with the territory yeah
you want to have the only people who
have kids that are not challenged there
are people who don't have kids who have
introverted kids and um
you know you should
it is difficult to have challenging kids
but they're the best kids to have
because they challenge bullies they
challenge people who say let's go
shoplifting or take drugs again i'm not
doing that so
be thankful you've got the challenging
ones because they can stand up for
themselves if they can stand up to you
they'll stand up to a bully if you go
don't you dare speak back and you sit in
the corner and be quiet then don't be
surprised when they come home
and someone's persuaded them to do
things you didn't want them to do
because you told them not to have an
opinion the greatest fear in the western
world is the fear of public speaking but
that's not true the fear of public
speaking is the fear of being rejected
you could plan your speech and talk to
him go i've got it all and i'm doing it
but the minute you step on stage is like
oh
actually no i'm not doing it at all
because we have to remember our
primitive brain our ancestral wiring
and it wasn't that long ago that our
survival was linked to belonging to a
big group the bigger the group the safer
you were if you were in the prairie
living in a four or only six people in
that four you weren't very safe
so we understand at a primitive level
that our survival is linked to two
things i must find connection
and avoid rejection well how do you find
connection you connect by being the same
you're like me
i'm like you
and so we understand that if i connect
you are naked but if you reject me i
might die and it wasn't that long ago
that we did you know we did think people
did things like banishing and casting
out and
marooning people and and banishing them
outside the village and so here's the
thing you know we want to belong
but the way we belong is by being the
same
i am the same as you you're the same as
you mean the minute you become different
it becomes harder to connect so there's
something called the true poppy syndrome
which is like
they have a saying that says the nail
that stands out must be hammered down if
you're in the chorus line don't kick
your leg higher than anyone else if
you're in school don't always put your
hand up and get every answer right
because i don't like you
you're not like me and i'm not like you
and so being seen
as wonderful as it is also risks being
rejected like imagine if you write a
book you'll go i hated your book your
speaker do i hate your speech
so the minute you decide to be seen
there's a slight risk you'll be rejected
i mean let's imagine you're in a club or
a bar and you see a guy that you like or
a girl you think oh i'm going to go up
and ask them out but you think
what if they go i don't want to go out
with you
and so now i've been rejected
so we are actually hardwired and super
coded to avoid rejection at all costs
because it wasn't that long ago that
rejection killed you
how do you get over that will you
understand that it doesn't exist anymore
you could live in an apartment on your
own
with five cats and amazon you're 106.
you could never see a children you would
actually live we don't need a tribe
anymore to be safe
but inside we feel that we do so it's
it's our deep innate fear of rejection
that makes us think i don't want to
stand out i don't want to draw attention
to myself i don't want to seem
big-headed or arrogant
and so i just play small
and the way to get over that is to
understand the truth the only person who
can really reject you is you
your friends could go hey i didn't like
your speech again i loved it i really
enjoyed it your friends could say you
and there's a great story i really love
about this doctor from a boston hospital
who decided to run the marathon to buy a
scanner for the hospital
and he ran the marathon and he came
somewhere right at the end and when he
went back in all his friends went oh
gosh that was so embarrassing you know
you came last you went last
no
i was first in my category what category
is that he went a doctor
from this hospital running to get money
for a scanner i was first
and i loved that because if you look at
that what does that say
everyone rejected him but he said no
yeah
category have you if you are you running
the marathon
you just said to me oh i love your book
i could write a book i said well go
write it then i could do that you know
people who are good at what they do make
it look very very easy but that doesn't
mean it is so
honestly the thing that will change your
life on a dime
is to decide the only person who can
reject me
is me i did get very sick like a year
ago and i thought wow how could that
happen you know i'm so happy and
positive and eat well so i was a bit
surprised when i got sick
but then
the same thing the thinking the belief i
decided i'd focus on massive healing i
kept telling my body that it was a
cancer-fighting machine i was making all
these nk killer cells and i did actually
go home the next day i was on stage a
week later and my doctor was like wow
you become the poster girl for just
going on with your life and now i look
at one particular
um
youtube and that's so bizarre i had like
major surgery just a week before that
and you'd never know
but um
again it it's it's a belief i decided i
do wellness i said i was like i need to
go home i want and i went and got into
my own bed i watched um ray donovan i
thought this is it i'm doing wellness
here i'm not going to lie in that bed
where they keep trying to give you pills
and i didn't feel any pain at all
because i just kept telling my body to
heal itself and then later i thought
maybe it's good i got that because i can
help other people and i go look you know
it
life throws stuff at you but you get to
choose how to deal with it
yeah and even then i noticed that i was
very positive because i you know i had
actually got womb cancer that well that
stroke of luck to get womb cans i don't
need a womb it's done its job i've had a
great kid i talked to my womb and said
thanks for giving me this great kid but
now i've got to get rid of you because
i've got to stay here and raise this
great kid
and i thought that's good i mean imagine
if you get brain cancer or bone cancer i
felt very lucky it was a disposable
organ they'd done a great job i didn't
need it and so
i think once you become like that it's
just who you are so i never had oh my
god i'm gonna die because i don't know
i'm not going anywhere
it is all perspective i mean
i still you know people will say to me
but i thought you were so healthy how
could you get that as it turns out i
have some that same gene that angelina
jolie has but but then of course bruce
lipton will tell you you can turn off a
gene you can you can mentally remove
that gene
so even with adversity because it's
quite good in a way because people think
oh your life's just you like pollyanna
just tripping along having a wonderful
life that's not true i've still had
adversity
but your mind will always kick in when
it's well trained you go this is a blip
just it's just a blip just carry on and
so you got to train your mind like you
train a horse you know i say your mind's
like a ferrari
and if you've never done a ferrari it's
going to go all over the place but if
you have ferrari driving lessons you're
going to run that ferrari the ferrari
should not be running you if you get on
a horse you've never ridden it's going
to go everywhere but if you have some
horse riding skills you say go there
and it goes so i see my mind like a
horse and i am the rider but i'm gonna
tell my mind where to go and it's gonna
do it the number one job of your mind is
to listen to your words
and act on them when you go i'm going to
mess this up so we're going to go wrong
i haven't studied enough i'll never pass
that exam
why would anyone date me i don't have
enough money
you're presupposing it when if you say
something different
you get something different because your
mind's number one job is to listen to
what you tell it
and act on it in the language of the
mind a few things to consider the mind
only works in the present tense you
can't go next year i'd be a millionaire
next year i'll have a hot body next year
i won't be depressed it has to be now
today so first of all you've got to
speak in the present tense because
that's all the mind understands secondly
you've got to use very
compelling
powerful descriptive words that really
turn on and excite the mind people don't
understand they say things like every
day in every way
i'm getting better and better better and
better from what
every day i'm making more money well you
could make ten dollars a week more but
that's not exciting
so you have to use really really
powerful descriptive relevant
up-to-date words and then and that's
probably why you love your tape because
when i make people recordings i
really excite the imagination because i
understand that that's what excites it
wakes up to good words and it doesn't
even understand what
undescriptive words are so people can go
how was your weekend all right yeah not
bad yeah
um
when i said we were obese how are you
i'm the size of a house i'm like well
clearly you're not because you wouldn't
get in the chair yeah i just eat all day
i'm an out of control train wreck i eat
for 24 hours a day without stopping i
said but not really because surely you
go to the bathroom
surely you take a nap and
and then they yeah i don't really eat
all day but when you say that to
yourself your mind believes that you do
yeah so here's the thing if you walk in
there and i'm starving oh my god i'm
starving i can eat a horse your mind
goes oh my god you're starving well i
have a little thing called an aposet
and it controls how much you eat but
when you've told me you're starving i'm
gonna switch that off and you're going
to stand in that fridge and eat
everything like a mad person because you
just told me you're starving
and you see 100 years ago that's what we
died of more than disease starvation
we're really scared of being hungry
so people think you know i logically now
i've got a quick chicken in my fridge
but i'm so hungry i'm going to eat all
those jelly beans and taco chips now
so when you say i'm starving you'll eat
like you're starving even though you
know you're not when you say i am hungry
and i need to eat some really super
healthy food then you and i wait an hour
for that your mind totally gets that
so you got to see your mind as something
that's working for you
and if you give it the right
instructions to do an amazing job and if
you give it the wrong instructions like
all people will work for you do a
terrible job i've always been in love
with the i'm enough because when you're
a therapist you're always working with
what lies beneath what lies beneath
these people's problems it's always the
same i don't feel
smart enough rich enough good enough
and when you say things like i'm a rock
star mine goes not really a rock star
because come on you live in a shared
apartment
and you've got a car that's 11 years old
you shop in target that's not a rock
star i'm a goddess it's not really a
goddess because you've got cellulite
but when you sign enough its strength is
its simplicity and its honesty because
you are enough you're not your weight
your shape your size your bank account
your childhood
you're enough
and the thing is when you say it
and really say it speak it and let it in
people pick up your enoughness and
believe it so
within that book you'll see that we get
people to change their password so they
contain them enough obviously with some
letters and numbers and squiggles we
can't find enough to be hacker's dream
come true
but you write it all over your mirrors
you put it on your fridge infringement
you put it on your screen you have your
phone alerts go off twice a day when you
type it out in your password when you
write it read it say it think it
it goes in and does the most incredible
work because
when you feel enough you can talk to
people you don't risk rejection because
you can't be rejected you take risks if
i'm enough don't just lie on the sofa
and eat potato chips no
when you know you're enough you think
i'm enough i'm going to build this um
company get a raise get a promotion
release my book
i'm going to invent this thing i've had
in my head for years i'm going to ask
that girl or guy out i'm going to stand
up to my kids teacher who i think is
terrifying me because they're not
terrifying
so i'm enough just opened so many doors
and makes you
like yourself because if you don't like
yourself
nothing counts
nothing you have is enough and that's
what's behind so many people we think of
everything
it becomes suicidal right
but i'm enough it strengthens its
simplicity but also it's absolute
truthfulness because everyone's enough
and the minute you know it
the whole world knows it and they treat
you differently you see we think i'll
buy a porsche and then i'm going to say
look i'm enough i've got a porsche
i'll i'll get an armani jacket or i'll
get
breast implants or lip implants and then
i'm saying i'm enough but we see lots of
people who've got all of that and are
desperately desperately unhappy because
everything you want
is because it might make you feel enough
when you can feel enough without the
stuff
now you've won and then you'll get the
stuff anyway
but you only get the stuff
for because you want it not because you
need it
to feel enough yeah
so if someone said to me i keep buying
all these jo malone candles to feel
enough i'm like but you've got 22.
and if you've they've worked why would
you need 26 you've got
18 pairs of shoes to feel enough
do you think 19 is going to make any
difference stuff can't make you feel
enough it's out there
feeling enough is in here and when you
know you're enough you can still love a
pair of shoes believe me i love a nice
pair of shoes but i never buy them to
feel enough because i'm enough without
them everything starts with a thought a
thought is a word and if you use was
elated empowered ecstatic blissed out
amazing phenomenal incredible i'm stella
i'm just amazing you can repeat the same
words over and over again i feel
ecstatic
i'm elated when i work through to say i
can't stand up to my boss i can't tell
my mom that she's actually the biggest
[ __ ] in the whole world who ruined my
life i go well how about thinking if you
say that it makes you feel elated it
makes you about it sets it free
because outrage is just rage that needs
to come out i said listen your anger is
like gas better out than in
she's not in the room
let's do it now i want you to say to
your mom
mom you know i want to love you more and
i can't because i resent deeply and
suddenly they go you absolute [ __ ] you
biggest [ __ ] in the world how could you
do that although i feel so good now
because it's out and i can go home and i
can love my mum better because i've let
the resentment out
so i never tell people to keep it in i
think feelings do the most damage when
they're kept in when they're repressed
and pushed down and most of my clients
who binge
and drink too much are pushing down
feelings the stomach
is the seat of all emotions you can't
heal what you can't feel
but you should let feelings out and if
you keep it in you always suffer you
always feel repressed many clients i see
who say they are depressed are not
depressed they are repressed and they
are suppressed because they can't say i
resent you
for always saying my brother was smarter
i resent you for marrying six different
guys who are hideous to me and never
putting me first and then they make
their peace and then they move on
you have to be aware of it
you have to accept it and you have to
articulate it i call it triple a your
brain is actually quite smart and it
usually gives you a phobia because it
thinks it's in your best interest to
have it now i know that sounds kind of
crazy
but the mind works like this it always
does what it really thinks is in your
very very best interest if you have a
phobia
and you haven't managed to get rid of it
that's because your mind believes that
somehow it's helping you so here's the
thing if you go to the top of a very
tall building and run to the window and
look out your stomach will drop and your
mind will go get away from the edge you
crazy fool because
millions of years after evolution our
brain still thinks if we stand right at
the top of a high building it should
make us feel slightly sick so we pull
back and now it saved us because that's
our mind's job keep you safe on the
planet so i totally understand the fear
of heights and you can't fight that
stuff vertigo is there for a reason but
you can rationalize with the mind you
can turn it down you can say i'm safe
look there's a window this thick i'm
going to stay here and breathe and keep
saying i'm safe i'm safe and then the
vertigo will go away because your mind
is doing its job gets you away from the
ledge and when you dialogue with your
mind ago it's not a ledge it's a plate
glass window and i'm safe it will go oh
okay don't need to do my job
here's another phobia it is probably the
most common phobia in the world the fear
of speaking in public you know that's
not the fear
it's a fear of being rejected i work
with so many people i've worked with
people who said you know
i can't even go to my own wedding i've
had to cancel the wedding because i
can't walk down the aisle
i've had grooms who fainted at their
wedding rehearsal about giving the
speech i had someone who had to speak at
a funeral she said you know what
i'd actually rather be in the coffin
right now than give that speech because
i am terrified
but they're not terrified of speaking in
public they are terrified being rejected
and that's again as far as your brain's
concerned that's kind of smart because
here's the thing we come onto the planet
with two needs
find connection avoid rejection imagine
you can go back a few thousand years
and you're born in a tribe and that
tribe rejects you and they don't like
you and they cast you out you're not
even going to make it you can't live
because you can't hunt and protect
yourself alone
and so that's why we have a fear of
rejection because our mind believes i
must be accepted
i must be connected and then i'll live a
long time and of course you and i know
that we could go and live in a little
bed sit with a cat and live to 102 get
all our groceries delivered and we don't
die of rejection anymore
but our brain really hasn't caught up so
when people have phobias of public
speaking which is nothing more than a
favor being rejected
the way to deal with that is to say that
i cannot be rejected nobody
can reject me without my permission they
can say mean things
they can be really mean
but you always get to choose whether you
let it in or not so somebody wrote to me
and said you know my kid's school
there's a little boy who's dad has died
and he comes in every day and he says i
don't have a dad i haven't got a dad and
he's very angry and what could i do and
i said well
not a great deal but you could um maybe
have him over for
did you call him sleepovers yeah have
him over for sleepovers and see what you
can do and so she talked a little kid
and he felt so different so different
so she sat with a little boy and said i
know you your dad isn't here but if he
was here what would he say and she made
him say it over and over again and i
made a little recording saying you're a
great kid you're an awesome kid you're
an amazing kid you're a gift that any
dad would love to have and then she got
the mother to write on his mirror you
are an awesome kid and that actually
completely turned that kid around
because it's what he needed to hear the
kid has to say it themselves you could
say to your kid you're amazing again no
i'm not you could say to your kid oh
look at that work of art that go i just
scribbled there in two minutes it's
worthless
so it's not you saying it
many kids say to their child you're so
wonderful they go oh mum you just think
that no one else does everyone hates me
or you say i'm smart but my teacher
doesn't think so but when they say it
the mind lets it in you see if i said
something to you like oh tony you're
amazing oh i love that painting it's
just painting everything's incredible i
might make you feel that you want to
give it to me i could manipulate you
with praise i could say to my pa you're
the best pa in the whole world i'm
you're amazing could you work all
weekend now i've kind of made a thing oh
we're going to have to do that now so
your mind understands that praise has an
agenda except
when you say it yourself
there's no agenda your mind says if you
say it
if someone else says it's like in a shop
and they go oh oh my god you look
amazing in there you should have that
and you need the shoes to go with it and
that's your color and oh look we've got
a matching we think i'm gonna have to
buy all of this now
so we understand praise manipulates
we'll accept your own praise your mind
says if you say it it must be true which
is why self-criticism goes in and does
so much damage and self-praise goes in
and does so much repairing because the
most
important word you'll ever hear are the
words you say to yourself
and that's the problem with teenagers
they're waiting for some idiot boy or
stupid girl to go i like you
and i would say to them look why don't
you like you instead of putting all this
energy into making this person like you
by buying them stuff and
trying to please them and trying to do
everything do their homework and give
them your lunch don't do that
you like you because when you can
really like yourself the whole world
will fall in line they'll
like you to the degree that you like you
yeah people fake it but that's not real
if you really really really like
yourself what do you what do you think
is your greatest challenge that you face
internally personal challenge as someone
who's
helped thousands tens of thousands of
people personally oh my goodness
yeah i suppose it's not a challenge to
get more people to understand it because
people need it you know we all need to
be nourished you know we need inter we
need nourishment our soul needs to be
nourished it's not about organic
avocados from one market that's great
but we all need this emotional
nourishment so is it a challenge getting
more people to accept it i don't think
it is because everyone i see oh my god i
love that and some people will go you
know i i listen to you thought well
that's rubbish but then i found myself
going into the garage and saying nice
stuff to myself
so
maybe my only challenge but even then
it's not a challenge is i would say half
the medical profession love what i do
and really go for it oh my god this is
amazing i'm using it with my own
patients the other half this is all
silly you know illness is caused by
disease that you can't talk yourself
better talking to yourself doesn't make
any difference you can't possibly give
birth
just using positive affirmations
it's like if if you had cancer and you
had a very good oncologist you might go
look you know the way you think
the way you eat the way you act the way
you rest can all affect and go nope you
got cancer chemotherapy there's nothing
else that will work and all that stuff
this hocus pocus so that is a challenge
but it's not so much because i find so
many doctors love what i do and go wow
you know all these illnesses are
autoimmune illnesses many years ago
there was a wonderful psychiatrist in
london called dr mortally and he had a
great expression so it's been my
favorite and it says the feeling that
cannot find its expression in tears may
cause other organs to weep so he knew
100 years ago that's beautiful so
beautiful and so true
the feeling that cannot find its
expression in tears will cause other
organs to weep so he's sort of saying if
you don't feel the feeling
your body's gonna feel it if you don't
open your mouth and say you hurt me
don't be surprised if you get a
screaming everywhere i've got this
screaming headache i've got this angry
red rash i've got this thumping pain and
by the words they're using angry
screaming they're saying i have rage
that can't come i'm not expressing it
but it's kind of expressed throughout
yeah because the body is very clever at
finding something
i worked with someone who couldn't walk
and all she was i can't stand there i
can't stand my ex i can't stand my life
i can't stand my kisses and you can't
stand up isn't that interesting
she had sort of phantom
leg pains because she couldn't stand
anything bulimia say well what makes me
sick is
my sister-in-law i'm so sick of her she
just makes me sick i vomit in my mouth
every time i hear a voice and then they
wonder why they believe it right because
our words really affect our reality
partly because and it's such an easy
thing to say
every word you say is a blueprint that
your mind body and psyche are working to
make your reality
so we we make our thoughts and our
thoughts make us then we go out into the
world and we justify our thoughts every
day
but we our words are a blueprint and
when you know that you think well i
better pay attention to that blueprint i
better not say this kid is killing me
my job is making me want to die
i'm so stressed out by what the queue in
hughes market well go to zimbabwe where
there is no hughes market and there is
no queue and there's no money to buy
food and then you can say you're
stressed because
your problem the cue in error on and the
bill is someone else's fantasy dream
come true you this freeway is killing
you you have a car
look at people on four buses i used to
take my daughter to school when i'm in
one day thinking that oh my god this
commute is hell and i saw someone at bus
and thought how lucky i'm in my car
i've got the heating i've got a cup of
tea i've got an hour to listen to some i
can talk to my kid i keep saying one and
now to myself well here it is
and i learned to stop doing that but
when you said how are you
nightmare
it is torture what the traffic yeah the
traffic the queue
people keep ringing me the phone ringing
it's torture well maybe if it didn't
ring that might be worse
some of my clients or models will say my
life is hell because people look at me
it's like really well one day they won't
and then you might miss it if i get on a
plane and guys hit on me it's a
nightmare we'll put on a baseball hat
and glasses read about it
then they'll leave you alone
but that's not a nightmare it's just
mildly inconvenient it's not hell right
it's not killing you but we use these
incredible words this is torture this is
killing me this isn't like this is a
disaster
what is well i went to the bathroom and
i forgot to pause my movie
that's not a disaster but when you use
those words because your mind can't
differentiate to feel like it really is
a disaster well most people that come to
me
don't go hey i've come to see but i
don't want to give up my problem i mean
they do with food they go i want to be
super healthy okay you're going to stop
eating don't i don't want to do that
you've got anything else there's a
difference between i don't want to do
one thing and i want to do it but i just
i'm not sure of the energy to see you
see the belief is what you're saying is
it's work
so much work it's no work so what i
would suggest for someone like you is
just monitor how you speak oh i forgot
that you've got a terrible memory i got
that i didn't miss that gotta tell them
and start to say i have a phenomenal
memory i have an outstanding i have a
reliable
foolproof memory so i saw with my
daughter when she was little she'd leave
the house and come back because she had
so much to remember her school bag and
her swimming stuff and her lunch and i
always say what have you remembered
because i remembered my lunch i
remembered my swimming okay that's so
great that you remember and very quickly
she went from oh forgotten i've got to
go home my mum's going to be really
across the no my memory is great at the
gate it told me
school lunch school coat and of course
if you go to any kid's classroom you'll
see coats and bags they forget
everything and we never go well it's the
memory you see
it disappears with age and i have people
of 90 who can tell you everything about
their childhood and what it was like in
the war
so you have to just make a decision to
tell yourself i have an outstanding
reliable phenomenal incredible
impressive
for perfect big words of course because
you want to excite you and if you say
enough your mind's job is to give you
that memory and then stop saying what
have i forgotten say what have i
remembered
and then something else you do is just
say
that will come to me you know
you have to understand the mind a bit so
when you're dealing with a conscious
mind the subconscious doesn't do
anything if you're saying
it's the name of that book or that
restaurant oh i don't know i give up
i've got term i mean you just suddenly
goes oh it's coming to my head
it was this book it was a tim ferriss
book i remember now because you've given
your mind an instruction what is the
name of that book
your mind will go and find it but if you
are still actively looking it doesn't do
it so
we have something good command therapy
you've got to command your mind go ahead
and remind me where my passport is
remind me
and and so often it's just really poor
communication you know people say oh god
i'm flying to london tonight and i can
never fall asleep on a plane i just
can't go just like well where are you
going
you don't go anywhere you don't fall you
lie on the plane and you invite sleep to
come do you go i'm lying here
my eyes are heavy and sleep's descending
upon me like a miss
because it's a misdirect of the mind
because you don't fall and you don't go
but when you say sleep's coming to me
and when i i'm in different time zones
all over the world i lie better go right
sleep now send sleep to me now i insist
on eight hours of sleep i need eight
hours and i tell my mind what i want but
i am very clear
very specific but not can i fall asleep
i need to look at it i've got to get up
in five hours and now i'm stressed i
just give my mind very clear
instructions you do have to train
yourself a bit
but if you use those words my memory is
impressive and infallible your mind
knows what that looks like and it will
make it real if you just go
i need a better memory
that's not exciting so excite it with
powerful words and
you won't be surprised or you might how
much better it gets but you've got to
give up this belief that it's work
because talking to yourself isn't work
exciting your mind doesn't work going to
the gym is work but saying every day as
you get up i've got a great memory i can
even imagine my diary and i can see
what's in it
if you tell yourself that it actually
really becomes true and you'll notice
that everyone who's got a good memory
will say my memory is amazing
i have the best memory ever they never
go i've got mind like a sieve i'd forget
my head it wasn't screwed on i would
forget the eyes in my head if they
weren't there
but people with a poor memory they
justify they remind themselves how bad
it is instead of
deciding no i'm going to have a great
memory you know i i've had a couple of
clients who went to jail and they
reacted an intro one of them was a very
rich woman who
went to jail for tax evasion
and she said actually she ended up
really liking it she is a typical
richmond she had a beautiful house lots
of stuff she didn't really go anywhere
everyone did everything for her she
didn't really have any friends she had
the ladies who lunch
and when she was there she trained to be
an aerobic teacher she trained to be a
yoga teacher nothing else to do she
really bonded with the other women and
when she got out she went back every
week to visit them because she said you
know it was different in there it was
like girls boarding school
i didn't realize i was isolated at home
and more connected in jail which is an
interesting way to think about it
and people who often people who've been
in jail or been trapped in their house
when in lockdown
so isaac newton i believe in 1665 he
developed the theory of gravity while
london was locked down because of the
plague
sealed in their house and so he used
that time
so i guess you have to think well you
know i can't change this but i can
change what it means
one day i look back and go well actually
there's a lot of good stuff what can i
do about it i mean we all go i just
haven't got enough time i would love
more time if i only had time to myself
well here it is
what could you do or learn or achieve
and i'm not saying it's easy because i'm
also safe at home and
i really miss going out and meeting
people but i'm also doing things i've
wanted to do for years that i couldn't
do because of time so silly things like
cook with your kids and make that a math
lesson how much does that weigh how much
vitamin c is in the skin
of a potato
do the laundry you know why do you think
detergent is called biological
you can make it interesting you just
have to
really decide okay what does this mean
to me
and can i change the meaning if when i
can change the meaning it will change my
life because the meaning is yours to
change and the interpretation is yours
to choose but the fastest way is to look
at words am i saying apocalypse
armageddon
uh
trapped stuck someone said to me they
they've taken away my freedom who the
government government forces
have taken away my freedom maybe but how
about they want me to live they want me
to be safe the government
has put this in place to keep me safe so
i'm safe at home or they've taken away
my freedom children can't future pace so
when they're feeling sadness it feels
like it's going to be for the rest of
their life and they do this thing called
tagging
i can't make my mommy happy and it's
always gonna be this way
my i don't have a dad i don't have
anyone to love me it will never ever
change
we don't have enough money it's gonna be
like this for the rest of my life and so
when you're working with children i say
to them something which i love i said
look darling this is your life today
it's not your life i know your dad's an
alcoholic i know your dad's in jail i
know your mom's working all the time and
you live with babies and i know that is
your life today but it's not your life
one day you'll have a totally different
life they're not good at future pacing
but that one expression it's your life
today you have no friends i mean i
worked for the little girl who had no
friends and was so bullied and now this
girl has got so many friends because i
always say remember it's just your life
today and probably tomorrow next week
and i taught her not to want friends
because when you have a little thing on
your head that says please like me kids
don't like that they like i like me if
you want to like me too good if you
don't you're lost
and i taught her to do that change her
energy she was inundated with friends
but they really respond to that word and
because children can't future pace
that's like when when you're
below two and the mother goes out kids
think she's not coming when you say oh
my child's so greedy i want it to wait
to eat they feel they're never going to
get fed again
because they cannot future pace
and so when you're a therapist or a
coach when people say you know i wolf
down donuts i i mainline jelly beans
what's wrong with me
somewhere somehow their parents made
them wait
and wait or remove food as a punishment
you you don't have that because you're
bad or we can't afford that and because
the child's mind thinks it's forever
they act as if it's forever even 40
years later
so the job of the child's mind is just
the same as the adult mind it does what
it thinks the child wanted it i don't
want to go to school i'm scared of
school and now i've got all these
anxiety attacks and hives and eczema out
with a little kid who had x when i said
darling i know this is a crazy question
but if the ex had a job
what would it be and he said well when i
stand like that and mommy puts the wet
bandage on my extra he called it his
sensible skin couldn't say sensitive he
said when she puts the bandage on my
sensible skin she shouldn't put any
cream on that baby and there it was he
told his mind as the mother did the i
want that
i want massage i worked with another kid
who had migraines at six very unusual as
if the migraine was your friend i know
that's crazy isn't it but if you wanted
to help you went well when i get
migraines mommy and daddy stop shouting
they turn off the light and we sit in
the dark
until it goes away so he'd obviously
said to his mind i wish i could stop my
parents fighting and the mind goes let
me come up with a solution it may be
crazy it may be harmful but the mind
doesn't do just let me have a solution
it doesn't think is it good bad helpful
unhelpful beneficial it's just a
solution
so
children tag on to these painful issues
of painful experiences and you can
change it by getting rid of the tagging
it'll always be this way it will never
change it'll be like this for the rest
of my life you can help them incredibly
and i'm talking about adults coming to
my office and go look i know i'm a
millionaire but i can't spend money i'm
so worried it's going to run out because
when they were a kid
they couldn't spend money they didn't
have it so people hold on to this stuff
so i think we're just about out of time
but since we don't know i'm going to
tell you a very funny thing that
happened to me so i work with a lot of
children and there's nothing better one
little kid said to me marissa you are
the magic person and you stop me wetting
the bed because you did magic but all i
did was tell her that when her tummy was
full of wee-wee can't say bladder that
this magic barbie light went up to her
brain and she woke up and she sat up and
she ran to the bathroom and then the
next day she called her grandmother and
said
grandmother
and dry and then she went to sleepovers
i excited her imagination i did it
several times in 20 minutes that kid
never wet the bed again and she said you
did magic with me then i worked with
another kid who said marissa you're so
cool you do magic and then i worked with
the big hulk and he went you're the
bollocks and i thought isn't that
interesting that the words for a man's
genitals
a massive compliment for women it's a
massive insult
so there's your language burdens
being the bollocks is a huge compliment
and being the female equivalent is a
huge insult so you have to make of words
what you want to make of words but if
you use powerful words you'll have a
powerful life
if you understand the rules of the mind
and put them into practice you'll be
running the ship
your
your mind is like a ferrari
and you're like a driver trying to run
that ferrari the subconscious is the
ferrari the conscious is the drivers
don't even know how to run this but if
you learn you can handle a ferrari think
of your mind like a ferrari and think of
you like a hugely competent highly
skilled ferrari driver
take that ferrari where you want it to
go
make your life incredible you know many
many years ago i was trying to get a
book deal and
i'd put on a little talk
about how to lose weight because my book
was all about that and i hadn't sold
hardly any tickets so i cancelled it and
the same day my agent called me went oh
my gosh i've got um
six different
uh publishers who want to come to your
talk i'm like well i'll just cancel this
put it back on quick because they're all
coming and it was that weekend and i
think she called me on a thursday night
so on the friday i rang all my friends
everyone said come to this talk it's
completely free
and and i got lots of people to come
because i knew that six major publishing
houses were coming to this talk and she
told me one of them was definitely going
to give me a deal if not all of them so
i only had friday and on friday i could
have spent ages
planning the talk but you know i didn't
i actually made a mood board i thought
that's a good thing so on friday night
i had an old picture and i took it out
of the frame
and i started to stick things in it and
i wrote marissa peer gets a great book
deal i i cut out the tines
best selling list and i stuck it in
there and wrote on it my book you can be
thin
and i did lots and lots of pictures that
marissa makes people thin i went through
magazines i cut stuff out i wrote some
checks out there i made this mood bore
really exciting and i just looked at it
and looked at it and looked at it and it
made me so excited about my talk
and the next day i went off and i did
the talk and lo and behold
uh at the end somebody came up to me and
she said oh my god i love that talk and
we want you to come in on monday and
we're going to offer you a book deal
straight away and we'd really love you
not to meet the other five publishers we
want you so that was very exciting and
in fact i did end up signing with them
and it all was wonderful
but i know it was that mood board that
helped me because it took my mind to
where i wanted to be
it made me focus only on success of
course the mood board doesn't say things
like well i might not make it
the mood board has success so let's
imagine you want to be a therapist
that's what your vision is or a
photographer maybe you want to be a chef
i want you to imagine you've got a mood
board and you fill it up with pictures
if you want to be a chef
pictures of great
food reviews from restaurants and of
course you're going to cross out the
name of the chef and write your name in
and said in black marker pen
to find lots of reviews and put your
name in and then write all over the mood
board too let's say your name is
alexandra richardson
you're going to put alex richardson
instead of that chef and you're going to
put lots of reviews and let's say you
found
the top 10 best restaurants and you're
going to call your restaurant the fox
and so you cross that and you put the
fox alex richardson's restaurant the fox
and just keep looking at that and you
write all over your mood but all the
things that work for you
people love this restaurant the best
restaurant in wherever you live in the
world the food here is amazing
and then you look at lots of interviews
with chefs and you imagine your
interview and you put it up there you
can even mock one up that's what
printers are for so mock up an interview
mock up everything and look at that mood
board mock up all the things that you're
going to cook that are going to give you
pleasure mock up the cookery book you're
going to write mock up so much stuff you
know a couple of years ago i was asked
to work with probably the angriest kid
i've ever worked with in my life and
when we started to work he said you know
no one loves me i have no love in my
life and
i realized that his anger was actually
incredible pain but i talked to him
and i asked him what he was good at he
said nothing so i asked him what he
loved he said cooking so we talked about
that a bit
and he's ended up being a phenomenally
successful chef he's got a great
girlfriend
he went to work for other chefs he's now
got his own restaurant his life has
changed dramatically because i found one
thing that he loved and focused on his
purpose
and the reason he was here and he loved
cooking so much that i knew straight
away that's what he was meant to do and
now he's doing and his life has changed
360 degrees
mood boards have been proven over and
over again to stimulate your brain to
excite your imagination to keep your
focus on where you want to go make your
beliefs
and then your beliefs make you and then
you go into the world and it starts to
mirror whatever you believe
so make your beliefs amazing i think
your beliefs good if you believe that
dogs bite you
you make that belief and then you act
badly around dogs and then dogs pick up
your anxiety and they do bite you
because you've made them nervous if you
believe dogs are wonderful and loyal and
man's with oh i love dogs the dog will
love you because
our beliefs our thoughts become feelings
and they resonate out from us and back
too as events that always match up our
thoughts and beliefs and when you know
that all you have to do
is change your thoughts and beliefs make
them positive it's like there's not
enough money there's enough money for
everyone there's more than enough but
your belief that well if i have more you
get less and spiritual shouldn't ask for
money and it's arrogant and i'm not
worth it
if you make that belief that's your
blueprint why don't you make a belief
that if i have more money other people
get to benefit too and there's more than
enough for everyone because there really
is well people change in three ways and
everyone should know that the first
change is instant you know i came to see
marissa and when i left i've i've never
smoked a cigarette since i just i don't
know what you did but i can't eat
chocolate i ordered a coffee i had
chocolate and i sent it back with no
doubt i don't eat sugar in any form so
that's very exciting the instant rapid
change which many people get and others
change cumulatively bit by bit like you
know
i did have a drink but i only had one
and then i didn't want another one and i
just noticed that
that change was creeping up and the
other changes retro had was i didn't
even know i'd change and suddenly i woke
up and thought i haven't shouted at my
kids for two months i haven't had a
migraine for three months and they don't
even know they've changed because they
have lag time
and if everyone expects to change
immediately and they're the retroactive
or cumulative changes they think was not
working
so understand that for everyone who
changes instantly others change
retroactively and others change
cumulatively it's like
i had
three driving tests before i passed my
test some people have one but once you
get on the road you're all equal
it doesn't really matter it matters at
the time yeah
so we all change differently don't
compare yourself and if you're
starting to say these excitements i'm
enough i'm significant i've got a gift i
can monetize it
allow that to sink in but you wouldn't
go to the gym a girl down 600 sit-ups i
should have a flat stomach now i can go
home and never work out again you go to
the gym you build a muscle but then you
maintain it yeah
and
i wouldn't say it's hard because i'd say
look we talk to ourselves every day
everyone talks themselves every day the
difference is you learn to talk to
yourself better
thoughts are things when you think a
thought you have an immediate reaction
that's why if you think about eating
your stomach rumbles you think about sex
you get aroused people say
i don't believe that so what do you
think an erection is you think a thought
you get a physical reaction that's not a
one-off if you think a thought a thought
has a physical reaction in your body
immediately
and an emotional response if i think i'm
embarrassed i might blush
if you say something moving my eyes
might fill up with tears because my body
is reacting to thoughts and if you could
all be taught that early on you react to
thoughts that's the fact here's another
great fact you can change your thoughts
anytime you like and if you change your
thinking
it changes your entire life so for
instance we're all saying i'm stuck at
home are gonna i'm safe at home
stuck safe you change one little word it
changes everything so
let me say i'm trapped i'm in a lockdown
you know we're not actually trapped
they're not sealing up the doors like
they did in the plague and the plague
they sealed your doors and you couldn't
physically get out
but we are asked to stay indoors we
still go out for walks we go out to the
store we go to the pharmacy
we're not stuck we're not locked in
we're not trapped we're not in prison
it's not an apocalypse
it's not armageddon but if you start to
use those words
it begins to feel exactly as if it is
that case so
it's really important that you change
your words and i learned that when i was
helping a hospital who had people who
couldn't go in the scanning machine
and they'd all say things like well i
feel like i'm in a coffin you know when
i get in that scanner and i can't move
i'm so trapped i'm like look come on
you lie in bed for eight hours every
night and don't move
why don't you just say i'm in my bed i'm
super chilled and i feel so relaxed and
what will happen is your mind will react
to your thinking
and so i had many people do that and i
was teaching nurses how to get people to
do that especially little kids of six
going into the scan and they said you
know when we tell them they're in their
bed they actually fall asleep in there
and we say we're going to play a game
now statues how long can you keep skill
still for
so when i actually a few years ago was
in a scanner which i didn't ever plan to
be and i thought this let me play a game
and then i went
i'm in my bed i'm so chill this is so
great i've got half an hour to just lie
here and then i decide to go i'm in my
coffin now and they start to talk to
their mercy you're moving all the time i
had no idea because i was saying i'm i'm
stuck i'm trapped i'm claustrophobic my
body was like get out
and it starts to do things to make you
want to leave and so
if you just understand
how you
are everything changes so our ancestral
brain is like
flee
fight freeze
i can fight
i can flee
i can freeze so i'm in a scanner and
it's like well
i need to flee this i need to fight it
and i'm like no if you can't fight and
you can't flee
don't freeze flow
i can't fight i can't flee but i can
flow
i mean nelson mandela spent 27 years
in solitude we can't even do three weeks
we're going to know it's hell
it's a nightmare i'm cooped up my kids
are driving me mad i want to get a
divorce i can't stand it but he did 27
years you know how he did it because he
said
everyone in my country is in prison i'm
just in a different prison to them if
they can do it i can do it and i'm going
to come out here the leader of my
country and he did
so
you know we we have this belief that
events affect us they don't
the meaning you attach to an event
affects you
the interpretation you choose to put an
event is what affects you so i'm looking
i love it it's great you know so much
time i'm having the best and i hate it i
can't stand it i'm
climbing the walls i'm going cray and
ripping my hair out none of which we're
not actually ripping out our hair or
climbing the walls or going insane you
shouldn't use that but
clearly it must be the interpretation
because we're all reacting differently
so
this won't affect you but what you make
of it will and it's your job to change
the interpretation and if you can change
the interpretation
it will change your entire life don't
focus too much on where you are now
because guess what
your potential expands as you move
towards it you know what that means it
means you can never know what your
potential is because as you move towards
it
it expands
so you may think i just want to get a
job on a kitchen i'd love to work in a
kitchen cooking and as you start that
you think actually i'd like to
be the senior chef in this kitchen that
will move to i want my own restaurant i
want my own cookery book i want my own
cookery program there's nothing wrong
with any of that
one of my clients just wanted to be a
vet that's all she wanted to be but she
couldn't be a vet
because she was asked to leave at
veterinary school twice because she
dropped out of school before she was
fully educated and they said no sorry
she couldn't afford to go back a third
time anyway
and she was so depressed about that i
said look it isn't black or white why do
you want to be a vet should i love
animals i just want to work with animals
and so i spoke to her
and asked her to consider being
working in a charity for animals and and
being an animal trainer one of my
friends a guy called jerry cott who used
to be in the boom town rats is a
fantastic animal trainer he trains
animals for all the different adverts
you'll see on television and for movies
too and so i got him to speak to her and
lo and behold she started off working in
a dog and cat rescue shelter and then
she trained to be an animal behavioral
expert and then she got her own show so
her potential went from
working in this animal rescue center
being paid to work in an animal rescue
center training to be an animal
behavioral expert
writing a book and getting my own
television show that was extraordinary
all because that was what her heart
wanted to do that's all she ever wanted
to do
and as she's doing and you know what
she's happier
and worthwhile financially ever being a
vet if she'd been a vet she'd be happy
doing what she's done has made her
ecstatic and financially more successful
happier in every way possible so
keep thinking about your goals
use that mood board and remember your
potential expands
as you move towards it where you are now
it doesn't matter you have no idea what
your potential is because it's going to
move as you move towards it what do you
say yourself on a daily basis is there
like a process in the morning afternoon
at night or
what would it be like actually when i
wake up the first thing i would say is i
love my life i love my linen and i love
my cup of tea i always wake up going i
love my life and then when i make my
love this tea
i love the coffee i love the shower gel
in my shower because i i really believe
that if you can make your mind get
excited by little things then
big things every day is like christmas
and i think when you wake up you should
go
what have i got today oh a world of
stress i've got this this this this this
so you should always wake up and go i
love my life i'm alive in a free country
i've got all this stuff to make tea
and life is great so i do that everybody
wants to be happy and we're all looking
to be happy and we seem to have this
weird belief that there's some
destination we're going to get to one
day called happiness but there's no
destination called happiness there's no
terminal you're ever going to arrive at
in your life called this is the happy
place if you want to be happy and why
wouldn't you want to be happy
here's the way to be happy you got to be
happy right now i see so many people
i'll be happy when my kid can walk my
kid can feed them so i'll be happy when
my kids gone to be happy when
and if you buy into that i'd be happy
when you're never happy because when
never comes i'll be happy when i'm
married i'm single if i could find a
great person i'd be happy and then you
know what you do you just swap all the
problems of being single to having to
compromise with somebody else because
you have this belief i'll be happy once
if you want to be happy
here's how to be happy decide to be
happy right now don't do that be happy
when i get to my holiday i'm super
stressed at the airport i'm having a
management but when i get there i'll be
happy because now you've told your mind
that happiness is somewhere you're going
to
tell your mind the truth i am happy
right now i've decided to be happy in
the moment
i'm choosing to be happy you see your
mind is set up to do what you tell it
and every time you say to him i'd be
happy when it believes that happiness is
out there and you're going there but you
might never get there when you go i'm
happy right now
i'm happy packing i'm happy at the
stress of the airport i'm happy
this minute i am choosing to be happy
then your mind understands the truth
happiness is now you're not going to
happiness you're not looking for
happiness and by the way
nobody else can make you happy while an
amazing partner a great career a
wonderful kid will enhance your
happiness
if you give that to someone else my
partner's going to make me happy having
a baby is going to make me happy having
a great job where i get recognized going
to make me happy getting praise is going
to make me happy you know what you're
doing
you're giving someone else a
responsibility to make you happy and if
you say to them here you go you make me
happy that will work for a while but
then you know what you're giving them
you're giving them power to make you
unhappy
i want a little baby to be happy and i
got it but now that baby is a 14 year
old teenager doesn't want to speak to me
people say oh you know you make me feel
amazing and then the other side of that
is you make me feel so angry and so
lonely and so unimportant don't give
your power to be happy to anyone else
it's up to you
and don't wait to be happy choose to be
happy right now in the moment i mean
look at little children
the rain makes them happy a puddle makes
them happy everything makes them happy
because they live in the moment
happiness is an inside job go inside you
live in the moment i promise you
if you make a decision i'm going to be
happy right now no matter what and
everything i do
you'll train your mind to be happy you
can choose whatever you wish negative
positive you get to choose what you
can't choose is what you do to your body
and your health when you're negative
you can't choose that i could say i'm
just a negative person
but over here is a positive person we
all can choose to do that but you can
never choose how you ruin your health
defeat your immune system paralyze your
autoimmune system affect your nervous
system
what goes on in your body when you're
negative is horrific because the body
can't choose it has to react to negative
you make cortisol that's a stress
hormone that shuts down fertility it
lays down fat
so all the stuff you're doing when
you're negative giving yourself heart
attacks and strokes and high blood
pressure all because you're choosing to
be negative when
you come over to the positive world
which is so much better
you have better health you live longer
you look 20 years younger that's a good
thing too because all the stress leaves
your face
don't have to take laxatives and all
those antacids and stuff that people
take because of their thinking here's a
great rule when dealing with a
subconscious mind the greater the
conscious effort the less the
subconscious wants who's tried to relax
who's tried to sleep who's tried to
remember
what's the name of that restaurant i
don't know and suddenly oh my god it's
just popped in my head your mind
actually is like google if you need to
remember don't go where's my keys with
my keys my passport oh my god i'm going
to miss the plane i'm going to get fired
it's all a disaster don't do that say to
your mind tell me where i put my keys
remind me where my keys are and do
something else it will pop in oh of
course i came in and i put them next to
the fridge
tell me the name of that restaurant i
went to do something else your mind will
do its job you give it an instruction
mind go ahead and tell me where my keys
are where my wallet is
and it will tell you it will pop it in
your head but when you try and start you
know the thing where you have to draw
and then go and empty again and now
you've emptied it out three times
looking for your password you know it's
not there but for a fourth time let's
tip our handbag on the floor pull out
i'm missing the flight oh my god
everyone's gonna hate me my kids are
gonna be furious don't do that
stress shuts down logical thinking when
you're stressed your mind goes there
must be a lion somewhere let me pull all
the blood away from your brain
into your heart and lungs so you can run
i saw this in action years ago i was
walking home and this guy was following
me and i lived in a basement and i got
halfway down the stairs and i knew that
he was going to come down the stairs too
and i got my key in the door and i
couldn't work out i thought i've lived
here for five years i don't know how to
open the door so i was so scared but i
had the foresight to pull the key out
and i had to stand back in the shadows
flatten myself against the wall and he
came halfway down he couldn't see me and
he left but i wasn't going to keep
trying to open that door because when
you're scared your mind just disappears
you can't even remember your own phone
number
so you have to fill up your mouth with
saliva and pump it around push your
shoulders down and then you're not
stressed but
it's very important when you want to
remember something don't try
ask your mind to remind you interfere in
an exam and you know my god my mind's
gone blank
fill up your mouth with saliva swirl it
around push your shoulders down and your
mind goes a wet mouth
is a sign of someone who's relaxed
that's why we kiss by the way before we
have sex a wet mouth makes you relaxed
we hold ourselves back because we're so
worried about what you will think
and now it's got worse i put something
up on facebook and then i'm looking see
how many likes i've got i got two
and now i think oh people don't like me
i put something on instagram or twitter
and i got no likes no comments no
followers
now i feel worthless but if i put it up
and someone liked me
i'd feel worthwhile you know what
they're doing they are giving someone
else permission
to decide if you are worthwhile or not
worthwhile so i'm going to tell you
something that is so truthful it will
change your life
you're ready the most important word you
will ever hear are the words you
say to yourself the most important
opinion is your opinion after all if you
went into a store and said
is this okay they just color suit me
they usually go oh
that's your color and that's your song
you know actually you should get that in
three other colors and you should get
this to go with it
it's very easy people in stores to
manipulate us it's very easy to say oh
you know i felt kind of
manipulating to buying that the
assistant was so nice or you know i
didn't really want that but i didn't
know how to say no
or my boss at work praised me and said
you're amazing you're the best team
member you are indispensable
could you take on this other person's
work and finish it this weekend and it's
like
what can i say they totally manipulated
me with praise so your mind understands
other people can tell you great stuff
but they may
have an agenda they may not but they
might
when you wake up in the morning
start going wow this tea is amazing this
coffee is sensational i love the smell
of the shower gel i love the sheets i
love waking up i had to make myself do
this and it completely changed my life i
wake up and go i love my life i love
being here
my first coffee go i love this coffee i
love my sheets i love everything and
that's not really true but if you can
make your mind be happy with little wins
every time you eat something it's
sensational
make a phone call go this is great i'm
reading i'm watching my favorite show
this is amazing when you sit down at the
end of the day to watch netflix go this
is amazing this is wonderful
you're training your mind to celebrate
tiny little things and when you get big
things
every day feels like christmas when you
focus on where you want to go you
actually go towards it the more you
focus on where you want to be the more
your mind
like a heat seeking missile takes you to
where you
want to be
so if you want to be an olympic athlete
you'd have to take a lot of action you
have to practice a lot and train a lot
if you don't want to do something
physical
train your mind practice with your mind
use mood boards i've done quite a few
radio interviews about why mood boards
are so successful why people
who have everything tend to have mood
boards now the mood board i made years
ago i put it above my bed
which is an odd thing to do actually
because i face away from it so i don't
look at it every day anymore but a
little while ago i looked at it and i
realized that every single thing i put
on that mood board had come true in fact
when i finished with all the um
things i was going to do as a writer i
put up some pictures one was hot air
ballooning and one was something else
and i realized that every single thing
i'd put up i think one was riding a
camel i'd actually done all of those so
i thought well i better make a new mood
board now with new things i want i wrote
down some of the countries i wanted to
go to
so if you put it above your bed do make
sure that you look at it better to put
it really on your fridge or in your
kitchen or in your office you can also
take a big photograph of it and make
that your screen saver
and the wallpaper on your phone because
then of course you will look at it every
day over and over again
but even though i made that mood board
and put it in a place where i didn't
look at it and actually looked away from
it guess what it still worked so imagine
how it will work if it's right in your
line of vision if it's on your computer
screen and i work with many many women
who are having huge problems conceiving
and i get them to make a baby board same
thing but it's a picture of a positive
pregnancy test colored into yes it's
lots of pictures of babies
i have them also put that on instagram
and on their computer screen so they see
it every day and the success rates with
using that baby board are
phenomenal
make your mood board the mind will
believe everything you tell it
tell it great things don't use
wishy-washy i hope i try maybe who knows
you know i took i had a partner years
ago is very ill and i took him to see a
doctor
and the doctor got out the notes and
went um
i'll
to make you better i do the very best i
said this is not the doctor for you he's
like look this is my illness i'm like i
know
if i'm a therapist we we have to
interfere it's our job it's our calling
so you cannot go to an oncologist that
says i will try
and i hope this works and if it doesn't
we'll try something else because it's
filling your mind up with nothing so i'm
very lucky i'm in the book in london for
the best doctors in england i'm not a
doctor i'm a therapist but they very
nicely put me in there very happy about
that because i can speak to all the
other doctors i said to some doctors who
is the best one that went roger kirby
without without a second hesitation so i
called kirby and said look we're in the
same book
i have this friend with cancer he said
oh that's my excellence bring him in i
brought him in
and when he said what he had he went
well i happen to be the best oncologist
in europe for your problem and i will
fix it you will be fine you'll still be
here when you're 75. which one do you
think he liked and he did say well i've
already got someone he went who is he he
went oh i trained him he's not as good
as me he went right i'm going to the
teacher not the student because the
words i am the best i know what to do
you're in good hands i will save you i
will cure you we're allowed to say that
in the uk i will make you better
a very different to well i'll try
we have this new drug it could work if
it doesn't there's something else we can
only hope i mean that puts food we can
only hope let's try don't do that
we this is amazing this is awesome this
is phenomenal
i use the same words all the time when
i'm teaching my students my rtt graduate
you are elated you're empowered you are
thrilled you're delighted this is
awesome this is amazing when i make
clients really go i love the words where
did you get those words i'm like well i
find the most negative ones and i flip
them over i'm useless i'm spectacular
i'm terrified i'm delighted and by the
way
fear
and and excitement are exactly the same
you can be on a fun fair screaming your
head off and going oh look at that will
are they scared or excited i don't know
do you because it's the same when you're
excited you scream
and when you're scared you scream so
whatever you're doing say i'm excited
and you'll feel excited or go i'm
terrified and you'll feel terrified how
do you help people establish meaning
behind well i wrote a book called i'm
enough and we have a program enough and
what that does is it takes you the
process of where does this come from
you're not born with this belief how did
you get it and when they discover how
they got it they're able to give it up
one of my first ever clients was this
beautiful woman very hard to believe
when she said i can never make a
relationship last
and it sounds so silly but she said that
her dad you said her every day you'll
never
ever find anyone that loves you like me
nobody could love you like me you'll
never
find the kind of love that i have and
he programmed when you label someone you
limit them so now she's got an imprint
i'm never going to find love like this
love and guess what she never found
love like that and all you have to do as
a parent is to say i love you because
you're lovable
and all your life you'll find love like
this love because you're worth it
so it's little tiny adjustments that
have the most profound effect on people
and it's never too late to say i'm
enough i can find love and now if you
give someone the power to make you feel
good you give them the power to make you
feel bad and if you do it to
yourself you feel so much better it
makes you slightly bulletproof you still
need other people we all need other
people
but the dialoguing with yourself and
starting with i'm enough
i picked that because i found all my
clients addicts binges bulimics
saboteurs hoarders compulsive compulsive
shoplifters they all went back to the
same thing
i'm not enough
i need more
and if you feel enough
you start to feel equal
see most of us feel unequal you're
better than me because you've got money
or you're more attractive than me
but no dog or cat says oh you're better
than me because you're a pedigree a baby
doesn't know that another baby's wearing
designer clothes and they're not they
they have no concept of that so
really what i'm enough is doing is
reactivating
re-manifesting and regenerating what you
were born with an ability to say
i'm enough you really can you can stop
being ill you can change the shape of
your body you can change your digestion
you can have physical things you can
change the way you interact with your
kids whether so here's a good example my
kid is a nightmare change that to my
child as age appropriate
there you go that's it this
builders are going oh my god that's a
disaster but a good build regards a
challenge when you said talking to girls
is terrifying you just change that it's
challenging but hey there's hundreds of
girls out there there's a numbers game
one will say yes
and even if they say no the only risk in
life is not to take the risk
that's the risk if you don't say when
you take the risk and it goes wrong you
learn something you may have heard many
many times about the marshmallow test
and the marshmallow test is an
interesting test where they took
children and put them in a room with one
marshmallow it's also been done with one
cookie and one pretzel
and they said to the children
if you wait
don't eat that marshmallow then you will
have two
so they were seeing how good these
children were at delaying gratification
because if you can delay gratification
you are wired for success
and they found one group maybe a third
of the kids just shoved that marshmallow
in their mouth straight away and said oh
i couldn't wait i needed it now
they needed instant gratification the
second group said no i'm gonna wait and
they sat there
knowing if they waited they got two
marshmallows a third group well they
were interesting because they they
really wanted that marshmallow they were
very much a combination group one and
two they wanted it
they also wanted to wait as they made
funny faces they turned their chair
around they tried not to look at the
marshmallow and they forced themselves
to wait and they also got the second
marshmallow so group one instant
gratification group two naturally
delayed gratification group three were
kind of programmed to be group one but
fought with themselves until they became
group two they resisted their natural
instinct to eat the marshmallow
and what they discovered as they
followed those children was group two
and three the ones who delayed
gratification naturally or
completely unnaturally were way
way more successful than group one that
when i need it and i can't wait and i
got no self-control it looks nice it
tastes nice bam i've eaten it and now i
kind of wish i'd waited
so i'm telling you this because
it does not matter if you are not
naturally grouped too it only matters
that you can train yourself
teach yourself and help yourself to
become group two
[Music]
because here's the thing when we're kids
we learn naturally to delay
gratification our parents say
clean your room then you can have an ice
cream
do your homework and then you can go to
the park
do your chores and then we'll go out and
have cookies
we all do that naturally with children
and then we learn to stop and you see if
you come in from work and
you are naturally a
gratification delay you'll go wow my
favorite program is on tonight
and i'm going to have this wonderful
dinner but first i'm going to go through
my emails do the stuff that's important
and then my dinner movie is my reward
and what happens is you get through the
way don't do because you're thinking of
the reward you go this is a reward for
doing that
other people come in and go no i'm going
to watch a movie i'm going to have a
lovely dinner and later
i do my emails and of course later never
comes because you had your reward first
and it is a classic mistake to take your
reward first
well you see for me i really believe
that
first it's what you do and then it's who
you are so first you're doing it and
then it's who you are and it's so who
you are that it wouldn't occur to you to
have to make yourself do it see i would
never sit on the couch again my case is
lost i just know it it's all going to go
wrong
there's no cabs out there this is a
horrible flight i now have a belief and
it really excuse me that there's no such
thing as being bored if my flight is
late i mean i just get on my laptop on
my phone i mean it's i have 24
entertainment empty out my emails look
at something the days of having to wait
and being born even waiting in the car
my little phone is like everything books
messages videos and so
i love that i don't really mind about
missing stuff and being late anymore
that when i was last landing here two
weeks ago i was hoping the premiere
because i was so into this movie
no he's hoping he's delayed yeah it was
delayed when the pilot said we've got to
go around with that that's so great
that's exactly how long is left of this
movie
but i think it's important for people to
understand that it isn't what you do
it's a bit like people who say i've done
yoga every day and now it's just my soul
like meghan markle said that yoga is in
my soul i don't do yoga yoga is part of
my life it's like you don't say
i walk my dog if you've had a dog for
twenties just get up pick up the lead
and it's it's who you are not what you
do
and so for me it really isn't what i do
because it's so a part of me
and i like it and so i'm quite lucky
that i'm pretty happy
and positive i really do love my life
and that's a good thing i know that
people say to you a lot of times yes
you're okay this is easy for you because
nothing bad has ever happened to you but
you actually had a and i don't i'm so
curious to know how you characterize it
you had cancer twice yeah um i was going
to say battle and then i thought i don't
know that she was yeah i didn't use the
word battle that's interesting so
one i'd love to hear how you do
conceptualize it of it
and then how you dealt with it i think
would be really powerful yeah would you
look at me say well you've had an
amazing life but you know my life wasn't
awful my father was a head master he was
very invested in other people's kids i
just felt like this kind of hideous blob
that wasn't interesting to him at all
and
both my parents told me i should be a
nanny because they obviously didn't see
any potential in me at all
but that isn't to diminish them because
i wouldn't change anything about that
because it made me have that i'll prove
you attitude so i was thought i could
never ever have children and if i got
pregnant i would never carry a baby to
full term
i remember hearing that thinking you
know i i have to not let this in and
that's very important to make a decision
i will not let that in so when i was
told i couldn't have a baby i thought
i'm not letting that in and when i got
pregnant i was told many times you're
going to lose the baby she's going to be
born with something wrong with her and i
talked to her all the time and told her
to grow perfectly and she did and when i
was told i had cancer i mean of course
it's a horrible thing to hear and i did
spend the first two days thinking oh my
god you know what am i going to go with
this but because i've taught my mind for
so long
to only go towards positive i found
myself on day three singing this song
and it was that song about you know
that's wrong i feel pretty and witty and
wise but it was saying i'm healing and
my body is healing and it's healing all
the time and i just made a decision to
tell my body look you you're going to do
wellness now and so i started to do
wellness and i visualized healing and i
visualized it being very contained and
i visualized myself bouncing back and
three weeks later i was on stage in
costa rica
not because i'm super because i told my
body uh listen i'm i i haven't got time
to sit in this hospital bed with
medication do wellness i i really did
command my body to recover
and it sounds like it's all right for
you but
again you have to understand the rules
of the mind your body does what it says
if you go i'm ill i've got cancer now
it's bound to come back and always
looking for signs people say to me you
know i'm a cancer survivor i'm like oh
no i'm not i'm not because i don't have
it
so i was
obviously surprised when i got it again
but i just had to do the same thing and
say that's it now twice is enough for
anyone i'm i'm done with that and i i
don't refer to a huge amount um but i
started to think maybe maybe it was good
for me to get that because i can look at
other people say listen you always have
a choice i mean i went home the very
next day i n they gave me a carry bag of
drugs like what are they i don't need
those i didn't take any medication
and i just kept telling my body but but
i wasn't in any pain did you do chemo no
no no no drugs no chemo
what was the actual treatment i had
surgery twice to remove it and actually
the second time i now think i didn't
even need to have done that i couldn't
want you to do chemo
no i was very lucky i got it early on
enough i didn't have to do it but i
don't think i ever would do that
not to diminish other people who have
but you know again it's that choice tell
your body to do wellness and i kept
telling my body kill the cancer
annihilate the cancer
never caught it my cancer that's my
cancer because i've got my cancer back
or i'm going for my cancer treatment and
when you prefix something with my you
own it
you could look at my shoes aren't they
cool or you're my great t-shirt
but when you say my migraine my headache
my illness my terrible memory
if you put the word my in front of
something it's yours
and if you call it the
it's not yours so i was very committed
to never saying my
it wasn't mine i didn't want it i felt
very lucky that i got in an organ that i
didn't need that was completely
dispensable so that was good i meet
people
every day who carry around with them
what i call the luggage of life it's
like a big heavy suitcase that they're
dragging around full of old beliefs i'm
not good enough i'm not smart enough i'm
not successful enough and i want you to
understand that we acquire that belief
we pack this case full of stuff
that hurts us
pains us
and weighs this down and you know that
case full of i'm not enough
it's not yours you need to give it back
you need to dump it you need to leave it
behind because it hurts you
we decide how we feel about ourselves
and we link that
to what we think other people feel about
us are they liking our social media
posts are they praising us are they
giving us compliments are they inviting
us out and choosing to spend time with
us and how we feel
is all linked to how we think they feel
we're all born with two driving needs
find connection
avoid rejection but once you know you're
not enough you actually start to set
yourself up for rejection you avoid
talking to strangers
the minute you believe you're not enough
you fear rejection so much
that you disconnect yourself but the
truth is
we all look to other people to validate
the beliefs that we already
believe about ourselves
so your thoughts really are a form of
energy that radiate out from you and
back to people that match your thinking
try walking on stage to give a talk a
bag of nerves
you'll find that you can't connect to
your audience they can't connect you
can't even read out loud in class when
you're nervous because that nervous
energy gets in the way
when you can present yourself to the
world knowing that you're enough your
energy is so different you make eye
contact with people you speak at the
right volume your energy radiates out
from you
and back to you people that match your
thinking that's why it's so important to
have good thoughts about yourself
because they give you permission
to behave with confidence with
self-belief that other people pick up
and match and reflect right back to you
in such a good way we all want to find
love and why wouldn't we being loved is
the most amazing thing but again
all the people i see
are changing the wrong thing in order to
find love i'm going to change my weight
my hair my body my state i'm going to
pretend i'm more successful i'm going to
pretend i make more money there's only
one thing you have to do to attract and
maintain love and here it is believe you
are lovable and when you do that you
will find love love will find you
and it will stay with you for the rest
of your life so you make your beliefs
and then your beliefs make you and all
you have to do
is make your beliefs amazing not
sometimes all the time because you made
it this far in a video i want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some amazing iyanla vans and
motivation check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you don't have to struggle
you don't have to be sad and sorry you
don't have to take care of everybody
just because you've always done it be
willing to do a new thing in a new way
and sometimes